Once vertex and fragment shaders became available, all this changed. You can
now program whatever functions you wanted. When you select a material and
lighting, what the 3JS library does under the hood is create efficient vertex
and fragment shader programs for you. However, you can create and modify your
own materials by using 3JS's shading material. Vertex and fragment shaders have
similar structures. You first define the inputs to the shader. There are 2
kinds of declaration in 3JS, uniform and varying. In web GL itself, there are
also attributes to a vertex shader, which are the values such as the vertex
position normal and UV coordiinate data. These attributes are built in 3JS, so
do not have to be declared. In fact, they have those exact names, position,
normal, UV. Uniform data is whatever is constant for the triangle being shaded.
For example, values such as the position of the light sources and the color and
shininess of the material are uniforms. A value is labeled as varying if it is
computed or set by the vertex shader as an output, and passed to the fragment
shader as an input. The vertex shader outputs these values and then the
rasterizer interpolates these across the triangle's surface. In other words,
these values can and will vary per fragment. You're in total control of what
gets interpolated. The more data per vertex that you want interpolated, the
more time and resources it takes. Nothing comes for free. The fragment shader
also takes uniform data as inputs. The fragment shader then, as a minimum,
outputs a fragment color with the name GL frag color. I say as a minimum,
because in fact, in many graphics APIs, the fragment shader can output to a
number of images at one time. This is called MRT, for multiple render targets.
Targets is another name for output images. Unfortunately, WebGL does not
support this, yet. To summarize, here's 3JS's view of the world. A vertex
shader has inputs that are uniforms and attributes. And always outputs a GL
position, and can output varying values. The fragment shader takes these
varying values along with whatever uniforms it wants, and outputs a GL.Frag
Color.